let's go umbrellas we've been doing this
series for a while where we Photoshop
celebrities and make them famous I feel
like it's time to take it to the next
level and it's time to do some really
really [ __ ] weird [ __ ]
so yeah in this video we're gonna
attempt to just make the weirdest
[ __ ] picture we could possibly make
we got a great pace going here okay I
don't I don't know where I'm going but
it's a dark and horrible place think
this is how Satan was born I don't know
why Taylor Swift keeps show popping up
in my head there's something that needs
to be done
oh my god I've created Satan how did
this happen
um I'm so sorry you weird it out yet
I am okay I don't know why but a [ __ ]
Vegas that makes it look too normal I
don't I don't like it all right I think
we got we got something here Adam nice
nice and the final touches I don't know
I don't know if that's the weirdest one
but it's pretty [ __ ] weird I want to
cry I want to cry a little bit
Matt I think we did a good job on this
one are you crazy
how can she shake I guess it became a
fab eliezer after all damn it
this is like all right I could just look
at it and be like yeah I appreciate this
oh my god this is weird already that's
when you know you have a good base it's
not that kind of base all right I'm
wearing it out
you got me heads I'm really weirded
[ __ ] out now why does life have to be
like this no it's so cute hundred
percent authentic photograph he looks
again I'm kind of turned on in a weird
way don't tell me you're not - come on
stop it
hahaha I didn't mean for this to happen
what happened no that's all right
I didn't need to sleep anyway I [ __ ]
that I don't know what I why am I so
aroused well well well well well well
well well well well well well well well
Wow now here's the thing that I always
ask myself before I finished can we make
it winner hallelujah I think we can are
you with it out yet
I don't know why but I want her face to
melt I don't know if the melt thing was
such a good idea
kind of ruins the realism you don't want
to overdo it as well you know and the
ship is ready to sail I'm really curious
how people are gonna react to this [ __ ]
god dammit Taylor you're everywhere but
prettier than me well I don't want to
know how you look like then alright we
got a lot of what the [ __ ] this is
good this is good
best nude amber how to make people smile
oh no kids what are you doing peds
don't do it parrots it's gonna be fine
don't worry
goddamnit he failed it's too hard I'm
not good and I'm not good enough to do
this [ __ ] this looks really gross I let
you down job I like to do ooh
[Music]
time I love these nice native name I'm
so childish like it's ridiculous I
should just get bad from Photoshop
alright now we just need to think of a
relatable caption and we're done I know
when she doesn't text you back post it
on Twitter and watch all those [ __ ]
retweets just pull in same that's what
you get when you're relatable
what's that do we have time for one more
let's do one more but I bet bet bet bet
bet better but a pepper pepper dip but
how about a classic face swap I need I
need I need I need a new [ __ ] hobby
that's what I need
let's say that and see what your
brothers think I don't even know anymore
relatable same things be she going on is
enjoyed watching you live it like if you
did hit subscribe become a birthday and
as always thank you for watching
[Music]